all right the time being 9
30 i call the meeting the house
public works and highways committee
order
as chairman of the house public works
and highways committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
and as a result of the coven 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
this is a full committee work session on
house bill
25. please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i
am confirming that all members of the
committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
extemporane contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access
to contemporaneously listen and if
necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar
on the general court website the notice
for this meeting complies with house
rules
and rsa 91-8 anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call 271
3600 or email
hcs at leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
brad greenland uh committee researcher
and christopher shea legislative budget
assistance
please note that all votes that are
taken nurse during this meeting shall be
done by roll call vote
let us start the meeting by taking roll
call attendance
when each member saves their present
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
representative mills you're up
thank you mr chair uh starting with the
honorable representative graham
president at my house in bedford i am
alone
unless you hear the dog barking
representative mcconkey uh
president uh in my home my office uh my
protege son is here with me and maybe
others pass by
representative is mills mills is here
and his wife is downstairs sleeping on
the couch with the cats
because she's a sleeper in it
representative samara
yeah i'm in my office here and i'm
present
yeah i'm in hillsborough and uh
thank you snappy tie today too
representative philadelphia thank you
representative
newman newman
yeah i don't know why i've got you in
this order but
well that's it's nice to hear you yep
i'm here in nashua
my husband is in the house i'm a
democrat
all right i'm sorry for going out of
order let me go to
representative clifford newton
okay thank you representative blazik
here my family is in the house i'm alone
in the room but
they're around they might be in and out
representative boards
and i guess after all this time
representative boards i need to ask you
is it is
boards as i'm pronouncing it or is it
bored is
uh either or it depends who you speak to
in my family so you're not wrong with
either one
which one do you prefer uh boys is fine
boards is fine good representative
kaczynski
thompson representative thomps
president in my home and stuart's down
my wife is in the house
representative clutier uh president uh
home alone and the claire
my the bedroom of my claremont home
representative edgar president uh
kathy's in the house right now but she's
getting ready to go to a b
meeting representative ebel
representative jack i'm here on the home
alone in nashua
representative abbott yes
um i'm here and i'm home alone in
hinsdale represent representative
faulkner
i am home and swansea my wife is in the
all right i'm going to make a guest go
out on a limb is representative grassy
here
as he is at home in rochester and i do
have family
rummaging about the house all right so
that will take out representative eaton
representative peterson
president in nashua alone
representative query
present uh in manchester my camera is
having a little bit of issues
so i'll make sure i switch over to my
phone if i can't figure it out before we
vote
thank you representative bunker present
in exeter
my wife is elsewhere in the house
thank you mr chair the roll call is
complete
thank you representative mills
this morning it is my intention
that we go through both the
capital budget compare report the one
that is
dated 318 21
as well as the draft amendment to house
bill 25a
it is my intention that we finish that
work today
um so that the drafters and the lba
can finish whatever changes we make to
the draft amendment
to the bill and that on thursday morning
we will have the executive session on
house bill 25a
so it is imperative that we get this
done in order to give
uh legislative services and the lba the
necessary time
to um finalize
uh the amendment to this bill
because it has to be reported out next
week
and i don't want to be here monday or
tuesday trying to do it
um next week with the report date of
wednesday
to the speaker so with that said
um i think that what i would like to do
is go through the the compare sheet
you all should have had uh gotten a copy
if you have not quickly email or
something not me but um
let it be known now we can get a copy
if if i could have a copy sent to me sir
i i have not been able to find it it's
representative brassy
mr shea can you do that i will i'll do
it right now is there anybody else who
might need it or so i just send it back
out to the entire committee
um jim phidolphy i'll
i'll take go ahead and send it all right
go ahead and send it to all
but make sure that uh representative
grassy is included because he's not
he's become a full-time member but he's
thank you for that consideration mr
chairman nice community
this is one of the disadvantages of
meeting
um either by a zoom or in a hybrid
setting
is you have to make sure that the paper
is to everybody
at least electronically so that we're
all talking off of the same piece of
what we tentatively agreed to at our
last work sessions
so i think that it is important that we
go through it again
and then go through the
i'm not sure how fast everybody's
internet is
so wait a minute i know in mind it
sometimes
takes a moment or two for it to
okay um
we shall proceed working off of
the uh the compare report um
on for date of 318 2021
and i believe for those who are in
attendance
um mr shea this is on uh your
yes it should be out there okay thank
you very much
all right department of admin services
the only change that we have made to
that request from the governor is to
reduce
statewide emergency fund by one uh half
a million dollars
but they also in the the lapses we
extend
a 670 000 laps
so that they have 1.67 million
in statewide emergency fund overall
any questions about admin services
we also agreed uh on page one
to department of agriculture markets and
food
180 000 uh
for the big our building at the big e
next um department
of corrections
um we made two changes to
to the department at our last one um
the first is the state prison
men's state prison and concord a door
replacement which
is one of their high priority
for 200 000 and on the compare report
it shows the men's prison
ceiling and door replace repair in the
close
custody unit at zero dollars that is
because we are using money
from lapses to cover their requests is
mr shea is that i'm sorry i didn't know
if that was a question to me
that is i i will say your name from now
on
decisions that were made last week where
you split between um
the repurposed funds and and new funds
and after discussions with um represent
graham
and trying to minimize some confusion on
what the committee was actually funding
we
tried to move projects totally over the
repurposed area
and fully fund them or into the new
appropriation area and stay within the
limitations
of um the amount that you had agreed to
so the the door replacement was a
project you had originally split we
brought that back into
house bill 25 as a new appropriation and
then put the closed custody unit
as repurposed dollars of 300 thousand
dollars
so it will be funded that the reason we
did that
is it's just easier to follow the
bouncing ball
um for future legislators and for
everybody else involved with trying to
figure out with the money
it became readily apparent um when we
get to it under the
the adjutant general where we were
trying to
match federal funds and it wasn't clear
where that
complete match was coming from so in our
discussions
we um did that as as you recall
at the end of our last work session
representative jack
i'm starting to make a motion that i'd
be allowed to do that in conjunction
with the lba
and i said something to the words that
without objection that's the way we're
going to do it
and i heard no objections so we did it
that way
but the dollar amount doesn't change
the bottom line of the budget
new money doesn't change which is for me
was the key thing
so anything about department of
corrections
all right department of education we
had bathroom renovations
we had tentatively agreed to six hundred
thousand
yesterday i spoke with um
communicated with i didn't speak with
the commissioner of education
about these projects six hundred
thousand
is for six bathrooms two
on each floor of his building he only
requested that we do
the the first floor which is where
um the visitors come and where he really
would like like to get it done
so i would entertain a motion that
we reduce that 600 000 to
200 000 and it'd be for modifications
um on the first floor and that
um that 200 000
of that would then be applied to
um national cultural resources roofs and
repair
and we'll talk about that when we get
there but i would entertain
go ahead and get it second okay
all right um as i said
we have motion to reduce that to 200 000
which will do the first floor
which is where the public is concerned
obviously
in the future we're going to have to
but right now the commissioner is is
truly concerned about
public perception of when he goes when
people visit his building
and so i told him if at all possible we
would work money into this budget for
that
but it is up to the will of the
committee anybody else have
um
comments about this reduction mr
chairman
yes didn't we take testimony and i don't
recall from who that the women's
bathroom
was the worst part of that building uh
yes we did and it's on the first floor
but if we're gonna do one on the first
floor the piping and everything else is
connected
you might as well do both at the same
time
okay um it's sort of like
um when we did
some in the state house they were um
um back-to-back type thing uh
top and bottom it it was like it's
easier to um do
all of them at once on the first floor
than to
um only do one yeah i just wanted to
make sure that was
part of it because the i don't remember
who testified but they seemed to
indicate that
men wouldn't want to go in to the ladies
room it was so bad yeah
that that was the commissioner saying
that
but and representative evil also
mentioned that
um she would really like to see that one
finished out having having been one of
the few in the committee and been there
to that room eyewitness
yeah thank you any other comments about
that
this reduction if not
thank you mr chair and he's i think once
again to remind everybody these are all
straw votes
and we will be voting for the record and
the
in the entirety of the bill at some
point in time all right
representative mills the clerk says yes
representative sumero i say yes
representative blasic say yes
thank you representative boards yes
representative van de castillo
representative claudia uh yes
representative edgar all right
representative evil
yes representative jack yes
representative abbott yes
representative faulkner yes
representative newman
yes representative grassy
yes representative peterson
representative query
representative bunker yes
and i will go back one more time because
i know he's on representative
philadelphia
yeah i got i got lost
looking for that compare report then i
couldn't get back on so i called the
number and i'm back on
all right i don't know all right i don't
know what we're voting on
we okay representative philadelphia
the motion is to reduce uh the bathroom
renovations
at the department of education
from 600 000 to 200 000
and only do the bathrooms on the first
floor rather than
the bathrooms on all three floors
yes thank you thank you and mr
thank you mr chair the vote is 19 to
nothing i
moving on to
environmental services we made
two changes um we reduced
uh one stop it systems uh by 188
thousand
one hundred and ten dollars which the
commissioner did say he could do
and applied that towards
the coastal flooding model and there is
a
lapse extension that we will repurpose
money
to bring that up to the total that they
need
for the coastal flooding model any
questions or comments about those
changes
okay fish and game commission
um we did not make any changes
um the powder mill fish hatchery
uh for 4.6 million
moving on to whatever
which is the department of health and
human services
on this we added the demolitions of the
wilkins building
uh 750 000
because that is an attractive nuisance
it's an abandoned building that has
burnt
and i believe that that was the only
change that
that added money into this
page four we made no
changes to the liquor commission
military affairs and veterans services
this is where it became obvious that um
to lba and myself that we needed to make
that the changes on
on how we were repurposing money if
you'll note in
green where it says readiness center
renovations statewide six hundred
thousand
and six hundred thousand new funding
that is to match 600 000 of federal
dollars
uh that belong below that um
what we had proposed was taking
uh from the line above it 415
000 taking some money from um a lapse in
and admin services combining them but it
was hard to follow
especially to the federal government um
where the match was going to be coming
from so it's just
easier to do this and use the repurposed
money
uh further down um and we'll get to that
and that was the changes doesn't change
the bottom line
but it makes the where the money comes
from a little clearer
any comments questions
i a couple of laughs all right um
roofing and repair under natural and
cultural resources
we had added a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
um um
i think uh representative mcconkey wants
to take
some of the money we saved from doe and
move into there
representative cloudy you have your hand
up yes
mr chairman i i don't mean to go back
but i noticed the top of page four the
judicial branches
e courts i assume we're okay with that i
didn't hear you talk about that
okay e court yeah we're okay with that i
just want to be sure we skipped that
over there
thank you i had you while my cuckoo
clock went off
oh okay all right but i just you know
so i think we're all set with e-coil
okay good
thank you another disadvantage from
doing things at home
uh representative mcconkey
um thank you mr chairman uh with the
savings uh realized over in d.o.e
um i would like to move 200
000 and added an additional
into roof repairs mainly for the state
park system
and if we can get an agreement on that
then i know the chairman is going to
speak later of accountability
and having um and having those folks
come before
capital budget overview as we go forward
to make sure that
that money is being spent as we direct
it
thank you mr chairman i'd like to second
that motion
uh thank you it's been moved and
seconded that we increase
the line item for roofing and repair
by on under natural and cultural
resources
by 200 000 which would bring it
1.5
5 million as opposed to 1.35 that is
there
if i could do the math of my head um
and you want to talk to that motion
um thank you uh mr chairman um
the uh park service and mentioned this
previously and another day the park
service is uh getting
uh tremendous volumes of uh
traffic uh don't see that discontinuing
we have so many parks and so many sites
that
that need upgrade this is a
an entry point for a lot of people to
enjoy our state
and with sufficient oversight i think
it's money well spent and it's been a
long tradition of this
committee that when we can find a little
extra money
we tend to send it to the state parks
thank you any other comments about
see representative edgar uh
yeah thanks john um i was wondering
i wasn't sure what was the total now
going to be uh
in this line item for the house for
for this item yeah is it's going to be 1
million something is it
yeah 1.
5 5 million um
it went up from the 1.2 that the
governor had proposed we had already
um agreed to going up 150 so we go up
another
200 so it's a total of 350 over what the
governor
proposed and if you look at their list
that they provided of repairs and roofs
throughout all of our state parks it's
well worth it
and i know over the last couple of
days and over the weekend i went by
several of our state parks both over in
your area
uh in the seacoast um and looked at our
new bath houses that we paid for
and then i was up north um
just the sheer volume of people already
using our state parks is
um unusual for this early in the
in the season uh with the transition to
the spring
so we we need to keep these people
coming back
to the state yeah i agree i just heard a
different number that's why i wanted
this okay i
i i may have said it wrong but
i don't have my calculator in front of
me and new math
escapes me no no i i think it's a great
idea i just wanted to make sure that i
had the right
thank you okay all right mr clerk
there being no further discussion that i
see
representative mcconkey i
the clerk votes yes representative
sumero
representative philadelphia yes i had to
find a new one
yes got you thank you
representative newton
representative blasic yes
representative boards yes
representative kaczynski yes
representative kolansky
yes representative vande castillo
representative clutier uh yes
representative edgar aye representative
ebal
yes representative jack
representative abbott yes
representative faulkner yes
representative newman yes
representative grassy yes representative
peterson
yes representative query
yes sorry about earlier i had to go run
and grab my neighbor's wifi password to
well done sir thank you representative
bunker
yes chairman graham
yes
the motion passes 22-0
thank you um
let's prove next item police standard
and training council
we had made no changes to the governor's
request
for that agency
the veterans home we made
see no hands uh community college system
of new hampshire
um we added
one million dollars of critical
maintenance
to the um
community college system now on your
compare sheet it shows 828
773 the remainder of the 1 million will
be
paid for with repurposed funds from
lapse extensions
so they do have a full million dollars
it's only about half of what they asked
for in critical maintenance
but they did kindly break it up into two
sections
and the first section came out right at
1 million dollars
plus or minus a little bit uh over a
little bit
um so i think that that works well for
them any questions about why that number
department of safety we made no changes
d.o.t we made no changes to the
department's
requests on there we did add
two um rail improvement
uh projects um for
uh coast county rail and the saffron
carroll county rail um with the
footnotes that you see
on the compare that they have to report
and it is
um match dollar for dollar
500 000 to coast
and 250 000 to stratford and county rail
improvements
see no comments
i will say that this is the quietest the
committee has ever been
because i think it's because we are on
uh
fuel i mean um zoom
um department of transportation section
two which is highway funded
we had that amendment that that was
drafted and we approved
and it shows here in the replacement
change in the fuel management system
and then delayed projects um
we added uh 2.15
million um with a net change of 1.15
million
this budget so that was the changes
and that was at the what the department
actually requested
um so we go from there and we made no
changes
to what the university came in and said
that they were
happy with what they were getting so
we have that that is the compare report
with the couple changes
and i'm not going to do the math but we
are going to come up
with very close within
a couple hundred thousand dollars of
what the governor uh proposed
in his initial proposal to the general
court
that was kind of my goal at the
beginning
um because we just need to
to live within our means
everybody have a copy of the draft
amendment
representative jack uh thank you mr
chairman uh two comments one
uh we're not using the extra two hundred
thousand dollars that we got out of the
bathroom line and um
and the second uh comment uh we learned
recently
that ways and means has increased the
revenue estimates
uh officially and that's good news for
the bonding authority because
it means that the as a percentage of
unrestricted revenue goes
up so that means the uh the ratio goes
down
so that makes the uh that makes the
amount that we're bonding even more
affordable
than it was that is correct and we shall
see
what their future they are continuing to
refine
some of those numbers and they will
refine them
and the senate also then gets more
updated figures so that they use
they sometimes
[Music]
change things shall we say and this year
hopefully we will
have committees at conference
representative philadelphia
yeah i just i just want to comment
that was it was good to hear you say
that we're going to be very close to the
governor's
estimate i always prefer to go with
the governor's estimates whether they're
democrat or republican
because a whole lot more people voted
for them than voted for me
and and they're the one and and they're
the ones gonna have to bear the brunt of
criticism from the
general public so i'm i'm happy to hear
you say
that we're very close i you know and all
the zooming and
stuff i can't keep up with the
the numbers and whatnot but i was happy
to hear you say that and i know the
leadership of both parties
on the committee do get together
and i trust them both so i'm
very happy to hear that and and
thank you for that um you know it does
make a difference if
if um as i said with
our very first meeting we work
collegially
to get our results and i'm glad to see
that that is continuing
we sometimes disagree about things like
coastal flooded
moderate flood modeling
but we come together at the end
um the house bill
25a you have
my draft amendment a couple of the
numbers will
change in that um so that this will have
to be redone
but i would ask that um
um line five on page nine
begins priority projects list
if federal funds become available from
the american rescue plan
act of 2021 the following project should
be identified
identified as priority projects for
funding and it's
blank last time i did ask
everybody to submit um what they thought
one time high dollar
ticket items for for one-time projects
should be we came up with a list
of about um that total about 41 million
um which i would like to include does
everybody have that
the first one is the forensic
psychiatric hospital
for 17 million 250 000
uh dollars that is currently in house
bill
2. mr shea you had a question
i just was raised to say i didn't have a
copy of the list
so at the end if you could provide it to
me
oh i thought you would get it when it
went to every i will send it
momentarily thank you yeah
um as i started to say the the forensic
hospital
is in house bill 2 with the
statement that said it should if federal
funds become available
use that money otherwise it's bonded i
want to reinforce that they should use
the federal funds for this
and not bond another 17 million dollars
for
for this several of
of the committee uh recommended that we
uh include uh the canon tramway
replacement
for 6.5 million dollars
which is a pretty close estimate it may
come in a little less i know
representative abbott was trying to
fine-tune that number
but at this point where it's a
recommended priority list i think we
should go with the figure that
the agency has come up with
representative abbott you have your hand
up
yes thank you mr chairman i the question
i had
do we have any idea what
is in this really fact for capital
projects
um my understanding
is that within the the
recovery plan act there's 122 million
dollars
allegedly coming to the state
for state capital improvement
projects what the strings are on that
what the guidance on that are nobody has
at the moment
i know that the governor has stated
that he wants to use all of the money
that is coming in for one-time
projects if if possible
he has formed a small working group
to advise him on
[Music]
this money that may be coming in
i have input to that small working group
because the speaker is on that
um and the speaker did ask me
for a list like this to talk with the
governor about it
but until we get
all of the guidance and
from the federal government which will
not be until mid
to late april at this point
our best guess is to put these projects
down
as what we would like to do with
with the money and continue
to press both the senate and the
governor's office
to find a way to do some
or all of that the third project
which of again several members wanted to
do
was wright mountain community college
under the community college system
the expansion in littleton for five
million dollars
um and then um
the roof replacement at the men's prison
in berlin for a million dollars
you will remember that that is leaking
and they are um
patching it and the same with the men's
prison
in concord roof replacement for 1.9
the under corrections the women's
prison uh construction of the trades
building for 350 000
glencliff came up a couple of times from
people
the roof at um the lamont building
for uh 500 000
and then the waste water treatment
system for 1.2 million
the new hampshire hospital renovations
c and d units for 5.65 million
and statewide energy efficiency
improvement projects
for 2 million which does have a
cost saving and payback over over time
and that's under administrative services
so the total of that comes to 41 350
i think it is a good list most of them
are one-time things that we're going to
have to do at some point
the way it will read uh is priority
projects list if federal funds become
available from the american rescue plan
act
the following capital project should
shall be identified as priority
for funding and and then there's the
list
as i've said i've already provided this
this
tentative list to the speaker for his
youth in discussions with the governor
i have not received any feedback those
discussions are just
starting because right now everybody is
more concerned about
representative jack i see your hand up
and
you're not recognized for a motion but
you can speak
all right i i wanted to uh
i wanted to just point out to everyone
there's still 82 million dollars
uh that if we get that 122
that are not covered by that so there's
plenty of money
to do other things that there
is and i know that the governor
understands that there are lots of pent
up projects
i mean i would like to go with with our
list of what we have heard what we have
heard
over the last month or so with what the
agencies need for
for bigger projects that we can't fund
at this point
um i am sure that the agencies
every single one of them once they
figure this out are going to be beating
on his door
um asking for their pet projects
um but when i look at the top three of
ours
the forensic hospital will probably get
funded out of this
the psychiatric hospital i know that
there is enough
groundswell within certain segments of
the population
to do the expansion in littleton
that they will be beating on his door if
the community college system is not
the department and others that we need
to begin
spending the money to replace the
tramway at
cannon um that is used year-round
um i know many of us have gone up in the
fall
in the summer it is a big tourist
attraction
so that is the list that i would like to
include in this
and it gives us if not a seat at the
table
at least a say in what we think is
yes mr chairman excuse my ignorance
but uh is there a time frame for when
this relief bill will be
expired uh
well it's in law right now and the
treasury department had
60 days from date of signing to provide
the guidance to the states
on how the money can be spent so
it is going to be another
three or four weeks before that comes
out
and then it will take all of the
departments and lawyers
and everybody else at the in the
executive branch to try to figure out
what the arcane guidance from
u.s treasury means about how they can
actually spend
not just the capital portion but the
other
uh billion dollars a little less that
will be coming to the state so
we will not have a handle on that before
representative newman yes
thank you mr chairman and and i'll plead
some ignorance
also on the on the roof um
for the prison roof replacement at the
concord men's prison
in the blue book the the number had been
a million
nine hundred and twenty thousand so um
maybe i missed something where the extra
20 000 was going to be
i rounded numbers i mean this
is just a priority list
if the project is picked um and i'm not
even sure um
um and maybe mr shea can answer whether
when we put
a priority project list if we even have
to include dollar amounts
i i would think that we have to come up
with an approximation
so people know what we're talking about
all right all right and could i just ask
another question of you
let me get that one answered by mr shea
first
okay thank you thank you represent
graham
no you don't have to put the dollar
amount in but i think to your point
to show your priority list it's probably
good to let others see what the cost
might be associated with the project
yeah thinking about trying to divvy up a
potential pot of money that's coming to
the state
yeah and as you noted if a project is
chosen
it would get reviewed again in terms of
the cost
okay thank you all right representative
newman you had another question
i do and and this is one i struggled
with when i was trying to
follow your directions to come up with
one project
um the land the land the five hundred
thousand dollars that the adjutant
general had asked for
i just wanted to make sure he had
something
and and i just didn't seem to be a
project it seemed to be a request for
dollar amount so
um i was struggling with that because i
saw a need for it
for him to be able to have it
my understanding of that is he just
wanted
money in the bag in case he found a
piece of land he wanted to put a deposit
on
enough money to fix my roof but uh
without having to go to the bank but um
um there is nothing on the horizon
that he spoke about where there's a need
for him to have that money
uh set aside and tying up
uh bonding if something came up
um i am sure that he could make the case
uh to either the senate or to the
governor
that he needed to do it but nothing that
i i heard
in the next two years i mean it's just
you know he's got his hands filled with
doing the other things that he's got on
there
um as well as some other things
okay and i i yeah i would just add i
think he made
i think he made the case that his
armories were
um i mean that they were at capacity and
they were fully utilized right now well
they they are but he can't recruit
enough to fill them
um okay that was that problem
representative jack
uh thank you there is a lapse extension
for land acquisition i don't know how
much money is in the account but he does
have some money
yeah and you know it's
it's there if he had a project like for
the members who've been here a while
he he did come in a couple of times with
um for the the new
center that that has been built uh and
they needed to purchase the land before
the federal government would build the
the new training center and and we
appropriated that money but
we knew where it was going ahead of time
so it just made some sense
any other comments about the priority
list
seeing none it will go into
um house bill 25 with the dollar amounts
as uh mr shea said if if
they get picked in the future um
and i will be lobbying uh the executive
branch and the senate
um to to keep that list in there
and to do it we'll do it mr shea
thank you represent graham and when we
included in the house bill 25
i'll put estimated cost over the dollar
value versus yeah
that way there's no question thank you
um but i think that by doing this
we do get a virtual seat
at the at the table if not a real one um
but you know i i get along well enough
with the governor's office and with
uh the speaker and the senate president
that
i think i can make our desires known
representative philadelphia
yes so i understand that this is going
to be part of 25a
yes it it if funds
if federal funds become available so
that'll be
that'll be stipulated in 25a
excuse me so it'll be stipulated in it
and when you rewrite this that those
projects
is uh this section
on page nine priority projects list
if federal funds become available from
the american
rescue plan act of 2021
the following capital project shall be
identified as
priority projects for funding
whether or not they all get funded or
not is
is something else mr shea you have your
hand up
i was just going to piggyback on your
comments representative graham and that
this list is not binding in any way what
it is is a way for the house to put its
position
out there but they would like to see
funded for projects if money were to
come
become available so that that's the
whole purpose of the
uh section as you see it in the build
now
so it doesn't have to do these projects
or it does
doesn't commit any money to it per se
but if money does become available
then you then the house has its list out
there that it wants to have considered
yeah and and if you ever
read through house bill 2 there are
other sections where
if federal funds become available this
is what we would like to do
we're just taking that a step further
and putting it
also in the house bill 25 it's probably
the first time we've done this
but we also know that this is an unusual
biennium in the fact that there is going
to be some federal money available for
projects
some comments on on how it should be
spent
the drafters i will get with mr shea
we will um redo
a new amendment for house bill 25a
um that we will vote on mr shea
mr shea your hands up i just i was muted
sorry yeah
i i keep interrupting um last night i
had communicated with you representing
graham regarding um a footnote
yeah i was just going to get to that
okay
representative mcconkey talked
earlier about our desire to make sure
that the agencies
are actually spending the money and
spending it
the way we want i had
um
um something along the lines of having a
footnote have everybody come in
to capital budget overview committee
he pointed out that rsa 17-j
colon 4 states that each state agency
with a capital budget
project shall report to the department
of administrative services
in the format um prescribed for the
quarters ending september 30th
december 31st march 31st and june 30th
all of the agencies are already required
to come in quarterly and report
what they are doing with our money
so there's no need to have an additional
footnote
as far as having the agencies come in
and report
if they do not then we can call them in
front of
the committee to to do that capital
budget overview committee
which i think i'm the chair um
but there is that um there was also
commissioner goulet of doit about the
reid uh retained in house bill 25 that
had been there the last couple of
bienniums
um they authorized him to reallocate
funds among the projects
within his department um
unless somebody has an objection to that
it's long-standing if he can move money
from cyber security to something else or
vice versa
he should be able to do that within his
own
department is there any objection to
mr chairman i've just got a call on you
mark okay thank thank you john
um i just want to revisit uh what mr
shane said about that
footnote and make another repeal here
um there have been plenty of times
certain agencies more than others uh
that they have a reporting requirement
and those reports
don't end up making their way there i
know everybody's doing their best
efforts
is there a harm to still having a
footnote in there
that those agencies on those i.t
projects whether it's des or the others
send a report portally to
to us directly so that you can
distribute that to the
to the rest of the capital budget
overview committee so that we can see
what's happening
um you want a separate report from
agencies that
have i.t um reports are coming quarterly
yes i i believe if i followed the
conversation from mr shea
that they already have to turn that into
public
in into public works already for that
but i think we should be sent a copy and
lots as long as it's a footnote on there
whether it conflicts or not
i i think it allows us also then to go
back to the agencies
uh when we want and ask for a copy of
that report
i think mr shea
thank you representative graham just a
response to represent mcconaughey uh
the court of the reports come to capital
budget overview
so the department of administrative
services gets all the information from
all agencies that have an appropriation
in the capital budget
not just the one you're passing now but
any open capital projects they have
which does include the i.t projects so
anything from doit
from health and human services um dra
for their rims so those are all in that
that um spreadsheet that's provided to
the capital budget overview on a
quarterly basis
that report shows you the appropriation
the amount that's
been spent encumbered the amount
remaining and then the status of the
project
so i don't know if you want something
more than that i think to the point that
if if there are questions of a certain
project the capital budget overview
committee has
the ability to bring agencies in at any
point or to ask them to provide updated
information
that is part of the purview of the
committee is to kind of oversee what's
going on with a capital project
i think that if you put a note in if you
put a note in the budget itself i think
it may create some confusion because you
already have a statutory requirement an
agency will be like why are you asking
us to do it again
um but if you wanted a specific note on
an agency
for instance the the the roof projects
for the parks
because you wanted to see what this
means very specifically and you wanted
them before capital budget overview
a note could be uh appropriate for that
but okay uh mr williams at the will of
the committee we can do whatever you
ask us to do thank you mr shave mr
chairman
could i ask that uh specifically on on
the roof projects
and uh des on the on the one-stop
project that we get such an update sent
can we do that if we if we could do that
mr shea
especially since we've increased the
money for
um natural cultural resources for
uh repairs and roofing that if they
could provide a separate list of what
they are
are doing with that money
yeah we can we can certainly put a note
in and um do you want it on a quarterly
basis or a six-month
so you could put a note similar to what
you have on the rails
yeah six months i think capital budget
overview every six months
yeah and then if you want them
sooner than that you can you can put a
request in for that
yeah there's no point having somewhat
yeah
six months let's do it that way
mr chairman yeah just just just to
finish up i wanted to make sure
that uh des with the one stop project
was treated the same way
that's a that's a monster project that's
been worked on for years and years i'd
just like to make sure it's moving in
we could do that as well mr schneiderlin
my understanding is you want to know the
committee would like to know
that's one stop and the
excuse me in the one stop
on the progress got it thank you yeah
representative thompson now
um i had a question unrelated to the
previous conversation
i have a note on my copy of the
draft of the original copy i had
on item number 19 the 5.1 million
dollars for
mitigation to the cloud not sure which
agency that was
but i had that circled and reduced to 4
million
was that a discussion we had had
and i'm not sure which i don't tend to
um i know that question was
asked of one of the commissioners
and i'm not sure which agency oh
yeah it's uh first um it's under admin
services
uh migration information cloud
environment
um we did not change that
it is a representative cloudier
uh sorry about that yeah thank you mr
chairman uh i just wanted to put in a
plug
if about the capital budget overview
committee which is the oversight
and and i believe this a meeting has
been scheduled our first
organizational meeting next thursday
april 1st starting at 8 am and also
early
right members of the committee who are
interested in what we do
i encourage you if you get to zoom in
and just watch us
uh and i think that'd be very helpful so
i just want to put that plug in for the
capital which is very important
committee
that in long range that right yes
meeting that early is to get the
senators
there and since we're different i assume
representative abbott yes thank you mr
chairman i'd
i'd just like to uh second
with representative mcconkie's said
about
the recording schedule and i i think
if we know that you're going to be on
the oversight committee
uh that shouldn't be a problem but i
just yeah
let me look put it this way myself
representative mcconkey representative
clutier
our members and representative mills is
an alternate
so we have half of the house members on
that committee the other half come from
um if i remember correct i have to look
i think it's all finance but
um we are uh well represented
and uh the chair is always on
on that committee so um that's the only
reason i knew
any other questions um
we will be coming up
with a new amendment to house bill 25a
which is what we will be voting on on
thursday
we will not go back through the compare
report on thursday
other than you should be using it to
check
the amendment when it comes out um so
that we aren't trying to do it
um line by line um on thursday when
when we are here in executive session we
can
everything that we have done so far has
been on straw votes
um the final vote is what counts
should be able to go quickly through
that
here is my plea to all of you um
we'll start at 9 30 we'll look a little
bit
at the thing sometime after 10 we will
take
um between i don't know it'll be after
10 let me just
in all probability we are not
um
going to have a lot of time because then
it has to be submitted to
to the clerk the plea is be here
um if you know that you are not going to
be
available thursday morning
please let me know i already have
representative grassy as
named replacement for representative
eaton for the executive session
the speaker has sent me that um request
if you are not going to be here for the
democratic members
please let representative clutier
or representative edgar know so that
they can
determine whether or not they need a
replacement
um for the republican members
either let myself or the vice chair know
so for the same thing um
important that we come out of the vote
united as much as possible
um is there things in the budget
that i would change if i was the only
one voting yes
are there things that you would not want
in there yes i'm sure that's true of
every one of us
or that you would want to add
but please uh make the the effort to be
here
and please let us know if you're not
going to be
the second thing i would remind
everybody
looking at a lot of screens with no
video
the speaker instructions
to all of the chairs are for executive
sessions
i have to be able to see your face when
you say
yes or no um so
um don't phone it in you have to be on
um the zoom call um and
uh with video i i would just reiterate
that
at least at the time when the the role
is called
for uh the final vote on house bill 25
and the amendments um i do have to see
your face
um i and i will live by that if i can
you vote won't count um and we can get
into that argument if that happens
uh which i don't think so and i just
you're you're all very very competent
and
um capable people so um
we'll just go with what i've said um
sorry to drag you away from your busy
days for an
hour and a half or so but i do
did want to get this done today going
through so that we know
what um we are doing uh
with the amendment and to give
the uh the drafters time the returning
members will
will recognize that at this point if we
were in room 201 of the lob
we would break for a couple hours and
wait for a draft to be done
a new amendment to be done but trying to
do it all electronically
i'm not going to try to leave this
meeting open
for four or five hours and hope we can
get something back
so we will meet again on thursday
morning
and we will do the executive session
representative mills you're raising your
hand
or just waving no i'm raising my hand
you bring up an excellent um
something that i was going to bring up
about the the draft men
i i would suggest that if when we all
get
the new draft amendment we do not
wait if we find a mistake in it we do
not wait
until thursday morning's meeting to
bring it up
please contact either either chairman
graham
or representative clutier on the
democratic side
so that we can have a a pristine
document
on thursday because we have sat in
committee sessions
for hours getting these things drafted
and redone
and i'm sure we don't want to sit here
looking at a dead screen for hours on
thursdays
so please if you haven't find a mistake
bring it to somebody's attention
immediately so it can be corrected
before thursday
thank you mr chair you're welcome and
representative include here uh yes mr
chairman and
uh representative mills gray's is a good
point but should we just
maybe make sure christie is he's working
on the amendment so
if we someone spots an amendment make
sure he's included on the email to
either one that would be
my only suggestion great point because
if it's a dollar amount difference if
somehow the
it something just doesn't look right
it would be useful but make sure
that um if you're doing that um
that at least i know so i i
i hate being surprised i think every
everyone does
uh not like that um but
yeah thank you representative mills
that's a good point thank you and
and the thing is i will say
that what representative mills said is
right if we come in thursday
and we have to get a new amendment done
which is what it
will take we will um
recess until that new one is done
and everybody come back later in the
afternoon on thursday
or however long it takes us to get it
done
um that's not um
the best thing hopeful it's my intention
that we be done by um
between 11 and 12 on thursday um
just but if if something is amiss
we will finish on thursday
as long as i have a quorum we'll
continue
there will be in the calendar for an if
necessary meeting
next monday i don't want to do that
because
timing doesn't work out well for
blurb excuse me committee reports for
the calendar
it's harder on zoom but it's still
doable so please do that um
any other comments or questions i'm
if not i thank you all for coming i
thank everybody
every member of the committee but i
especially thank mr
shea and the drafters for all of the
hard work that they've been putting
into this for us um to make sure that
it's right
um um and i thank the committee for
for attending and all of the work that
you put
have put into the thoughts and and
looking at what the agencies have
um are we going to see the uh comparison
report again
perhaps after the senate gets gets a
hand a handle on this um
we will you will see a new one mr shea i
think we can send out a new one
based on the couple changes from today
to the committee
um we will see one yes
i think one thing would be helpful is to
see the uh the allocation of the lapse
funds on the same or the next line
if if we have it split especially just
so we can we can see the whole project
uh
together uh you know
list the bond the general bond funds on
one line and list the
okay i'll talk with mr shea about about
something like that but as far as what
the senate does
we won't see that compare report until
the senate
is finished and we're headed towards a
committee conference
mr shea thank you representative graham
what i could do on the compare report is
um after the project in on the same line
that the project's named if it's
there's money in the um lapsed
repurposed money
i can just put a note to say the amount
so for instance the uh
the flood modeling project
note after that to say that there's 189
000 or whatever the amount was that's
under the repurposed section
and give you the section number
that that will work i think that's
helpful
representative jack uh yeah the one item
that uh
doesn't show up at all in the compare
report that's uh big is the turning
basin
and we didn't even discuss it this
morning
um that shows up in the back
it is fully funded through
um um repurposing money
and from lapses yeah it shows up back
there
um and so
it it would not show up in a compare
report
comparing what the governor did to us
but it is there for the 1.7
million um and it will be highl
i will put it into our uh
committee report saying this is how
we've used some of the money that we've
been able to
repurpose for you know our our commerce
seeing no other hands um
be on the lookout for the draft um
amendment
and i will
if you see anything that needs to be
done
let me know and i will see you all
on thursday uh
[Music]
work session of public works and
highways
committee is adjourned thank you all for
coming
yes thank you very much uh mr chairman
john appreciate